Black Friday and full gear tens of
millions of Americans are starting their
holiday shopping this morning the
National Retail Federation estimates
more than 116 million people will shop
on this Black Friday 65 percent of this
weekend's shoppers say they want to take
advantage of retailers deals and
promotions
Consumer Reports digital lifestyle
editor Elliot Wyler is here with us good
morning happy Black Friday good morning
have you Black Friday to you guys too so
I'm gonna start with what I was doing
yesterday watching football on TV and
realizing where should people be looking
if they're looking for that so TVs have
really taken over Black Friday you're
seeing these doorbuster deals with
extraordinarily low prices on certain
models so many of the major retailers
have them Consumer Reports identified
two that we think stand out as pretty
good deals the first one is a Samsung
model that's available at Costco and
BJ's it's a warehouse model which is
called a derivative model what that
really means is it may have one or two
fewer features than the Samsung model
you could buy at let's say and
electronics retailer like a Best Buy but
functionally it did well in our test in
HDMI input or something maybe the remote
slightly different the styling might be
different but the performance should be
close to if not identical to the other
one now if you want to go a little bit
lower in price that one was $650 there's
one of these doorbuster sales at Walmart
it is a sharp tv for $249 writing this
down I'm like okay I'm going so again
you know you may trade off a feature or
two here or there but the picture
performance was quite good if you're
looking for a guest bedroom or a garage
and or just a 50-inch TV you know that
that's a really good price and again
this whole weekend basically from you
know Thanksgiving Day Black Friday
through Cyber Monday are some of the
lowest prices on TVs throughout the year
E
what about other appliances not
televisions that are on sale exactly I
think a lot of people overlook that but
November our research shows is actually
the lowest prices to buy major
appliances not a lot of people are
wrapping them up for Christmas but if
you are doing some home remodeling or
you're having people over appliance
suites are great we found a whirlpool
appliance suite at Best Buy for $18.99
you're going to get a gift card there
what do you get in the Whirlpool's so
you're gonna get a side-by-side
refrigerator electric range dishwasher
and in over the range microwave that's a
lot of stuff for two thousand dollars
all of them did pretty well in the test
the microwave
we found better performing microwaves
but again if you're just using it for
kind of basic test should be just fine
for you
so Amazon's offering discounts on its
newly revamped eco show I just got used
to the echo what right yeah echo show
well so the echo show has a screen so
it's one of these and Google has one of
these as well you can see it there so it
kind of gives you the visual
functionality of what the echo offers
this is kind of the next phase of these
interactive devices that are going to be
in your home should mention too that
Amazon because of course they want you
to buy these echo products every echo
product is on sale this is one of the
Consumer Reports tested than it did
quite well not always on sale Apple
products but there is a way to get a
deal right and your apples tough because
you rarely on sale so for Apple and
Black Friday you're gonna probably want
to stay away from the Apple Store so the
Apple Store does have some Apple gift
cards available for certain products but
Walmart Target and Best Buy they all
have certain Apple products on sale
Costco has a great iPad that's on sale
as well so it's a little bit trickier
with Apple you're right because they
rarely go on sale this one at Costco for
$250 is quite a good deal shopping for
the iPhone is a little bit trickier
that's on my list of things to do today
it might take two stores I'm determined
to get some today is your day yeah this
is the Super Bowl for us Consumer
Reports thank you so much you guys time
and guidance for more Consumer Reports
picks for the best Black Friday deals
and shopping tips visit our website CBS
this morning calm